(swoosh and crash)
- Hello, Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
I'm going to share my
seven tips and tricks
to help you get more subscribers quickly.
♫ Nine
♫ Eight
(upbeat electronic music)
♫ Seven
So one of the questions I
get asked a lot by you guys
who are watching my YouTube channel,
you've seen the growth that I've had
over the past couple of years
and past couple months
especially, as well.
And you ask how do I get more subscribers?
How do I grow my channel?
How do I get people
interested in my content?
And today I'm going to share
with you my seven ways,
my seven tips to help you
get more subscribers quickly.
(electronic music)
Tip number one is create
content that you love.
It's a basic.
You have to create content that you love.
Most of the content that
you guys are putting out,
you don't really love.
It's actually not that good.
My goal is I want to create
content that I'm deeply proud of,
that I want to show my grandkids.
I want my grandkids to watch this video.
If my grandkids wanted to create
any kind of social media channel,
whatever is around when my grandkids
are old enough to create content,
these strategies are still applicable.
I want them to watch
this video and be proud.
Like, this is a great video.
Look at what Grandpa Evan created, right?
Like, you have to love your content.
And I think the challenge
is so many people
are trying to be everywhere.
You're trying to be across
all these different platforms.
And as a result, you do
everything really poorly.
It's not about just promoting
whatever coupon code you have
or whatever launch product.
The people don't care about your spam.
They want valuable content.
Think about why you
subscribe to this channel.
Why did you subscribe?
You subscribed because
somewhere along the line,
you saw a video that really helped you
and maybe you watched a couple of them.
Maybe you watched five videos
and you're like, huh, this Evan guy.
He's not that bad.
I'm going to subscribe.
Right?
So thinking about that,
thinking about who you subscribe to,
are you creating that kind of
content for your followers?
Because if the must watch videos
that you have subscribed to.
People must watch Instagramers,
or people on Twitter,
or people on Facebook, that you follow
that you want to consume every day,
they're proud of their work.
They put a lot of love into it.
And are you creating
content at that level?
It doesn't mean you have to do what I do
or do what anybody else does.
But it's the same level,
the level of love that I
put in to making my content,
the level of pride that
I have in my content.
Are you taking that same approach
and bringing the same level
of pride and love into what you're doing?
If you do that, and not being,
you need to focus better,
pick one platform and make it awesome
instead of going everywhere,
then you'll start to get more subscribers.
(electronic music)
Tip number two is be consistent.
Super important, especially
with social media.
You've got to be consistent,
consistent, consistent.
I mean, it's everything.
In entrepreneurship, you
have to be consistent.
You have to take action everyday.
Too many people, and I did
this at the beginning as well,
I'd make one video a month
and make a video and then stop,
and then start and then stop.
And then a video a week, and then stop.
We have these moments.
And if you're not consistent,
like if you look at my traction on YouTube
as an example since we're here on YouTube,
it really started to take off
when I was doing one video a day.
It's when the subscribers
started to really grow.
One video a day, I did two videos a day,
that was really the big moment.
And then we do three videos a day now.
The difference between
two and three is not huge,
but we still continued to do it.
Consistency.
You need to have consistent contact.
Because you get dropped out so easily,
and you create a storyline.
And people want to see
what you're doing next.
If you're doing vlogs and
you're talking about your day,
people want to see what'll happen next.
If you're talking about
your business or your ideas,
they want to see next.
It's a continuation, telling
me what's happening next.
They want to see it.
If I just created one piece
of content every month,
I wouldn't have as big a YouTube channel.
I wouldn't have as many subscribers.
I wouldn't have the
big impact that I have.
And so, if you want to
really have success,
you have to commit, especially
with a YouTube world.
I've been looking at at least
a number of videos a week.
I try to get to one video a day.
It's really important.
But consistent, consistent,
consistent content
and if it's a business,
consistency every day doing something.
Even if it's half an hour a day,
just something to grow your brain
and create for your business.
(electronic music)
Tip number three is
understand the algorithm.
Every social media network
has different algorithms,
and so it's really important to understand
the algorithm that you are playing with.
It's how you can win against bigger guys
if you don't have the talent,
if you don't have the production ability,
if you don't have the
graphic design or the camera
or the lighting or anything else.
It's how you can beat the bigger guys
and people ahead of you in your field
and get more subscribers
because you understand the algorithms.
So YouTube has their own algorithm
and Facebook has their own algorithm
and Twitter has its own algorithm,
everybody has their own algorithm.
Twitter's more based
on the different tools,
but still top, right?
To hit top for different keywords.
Everybody has their own algorithm.
You got to understand
how the algorithm works.
So, the algorithm I
understand best is YouTube.
And it's where I've had the most success
and where I spend the most amount of time.
And so I track the difference between
posting a video a week to a video a day
to two videos a day to three videos a day.
I can tell you there's a huge gap
between a video a week and a video a day.
You can see, if you keep your
production quality stable,
even if you drop your
production quality a little bit,
you'll still get way more subscribers
and make way more views
going daily than weekly.
It's not an opinion.
In fact, it happens.
It's my channel.
It's other channels.
It's consistency.
One video a day to two videos a day.
Same thing.
It's not my opinion.
There's data, it works.
If you do two videos a day,
and they're decent, right?
Even slightly lower quality,
if they're crap, it's not going to work,
but even slightly lower quality
compared to one video a day,
you'll see growth.
And again, between two and three,
there's not a huge difference.
I track it, I follow it, I know it.
A video that's one minute
long versus 10 minutes long.
The 10 minute video will
crush it every time.
Even a five minute versus a 10 minute.
Look at my Entspresso series.
It used to be around
four or five minutes long
and now we're moving towards
nine, 10, 11, 12 minutes long
because that's how the
YouTube algorithm works.
We tack on bonus clips at the end of it
because it's going to double
the watch time on the video.
Double the watch time,
then you get more views.
You get more views, you get
more subscribers, right?
So understanding what YouTube wants
on top of making quality content.
It's both.
Can you win with insanely quality content
and just ignore the algorithm?
Yes.
You can.
But you're hurting yourself.
You have to be so insanely good
that people just share it and it explodes
to just ignore the algorithm.
You're creating with one
hand tied behind your back.
It's doable, but why would you want to?
Where you can, if you
understand the algorithm,
even have less talent and win
because you're playing to the system.
And so whatever network
you're trying to plan on,
understand the algorithm.
And it's not that hard to figure out.
There's a lot of people talking about it.
To get to the 80% knowledge is super fast.
Within a day, you can understand
80% of what you need to know.
Where I'm playing at now,
a lot of the stuff I'm testing
nobody else has tested.
I'm talking to the YouTube team.
They've never seen anybody
doing what we're doing.
So nobody knows.
There is no data.
We're trying to prove the data.
But I'm playing in the last 20%.
I'm playing in the last 5%, right?
The things that we're
trying on my channel,
which you don't need to do necessarily.
Just understanding the first 80%
that will take you a day to understand
will already put you ahead
of most of your competition.
So understand the algorithm.
(electronic music)
Tip number four is form collaborations.
Find people.
It's one of the fastest
ways to grow any business.
Find people who are already
styling to your target market
and find a way to work with them
so that your message
can reach those people.
So in a YouTube context, find
people who are already surfing
your target audience,
same similar audience,
and find a way to
collaborate, work together.
And the ones that I've
found the best results with
are the ones that are non-competitve
and also where I can
provide some value to them
and I've already subscribed to them.
So if I look in the YouTube world,
some of my first bigger
YouTube collaborations
was with Tim Schmoyer and Derral Eves.
And I had smaller channels
in both of them at the time,
and I was a subscriber to them.
And I was consuming all of their content.
Back to the understand
the algorithm, right?
I wanted to learn that 80% plus.
And so I watched every video they had,
I was commenting and I knew about them.
I was fans of them, and so
when I reached out to them
to say hey, I see you're doing this.
You're talking to YouTubers.
I bring this perspective.
I think I can help.
I think my entrepreneurial background,
I think I have a message
that could be useful to you.
And for Tim, we've done four videos,
I think, that were standalone.
And then he invited me to
his YouTube mastermind group
that we did another 12
videos or maybe 16 videos?
I don't remember.
So there's a lot of content
on Tim's channel that I'm in.
With Derral, we did one video.
It was about public speaking.
How to get public speaking
gains through YouTube.
It's something that I've done
and shared my experience.
And so the easiest collaborations to make
I find are the ones where
you're already a fan of the channel,
you're already subscribed.
It already means you have
some kind of vibe together.
You like that person's
style for whatever reason.
As opposed to the cold outreaches
where you don't know anything about them.
But if there's some way
that you can add value
to their channel, to their content,
and they can promote
you to their audience,
then it's an easy way to
bring more people to you.
(electronic music)
Tip number five is have a business model.
You got to figure out how to
make money off of this, right?
You're posting all this
content to social media.
You have to have a
business model around it
that feeds the system,
that feeds the content,
that allows you to build a team.
When I started, you know,
I hate making content,
I hate investing anything with money
until I'm making money, right?
I hate spending money
until I'm making money.
So I got to figure out a way.
How do I make money off of
everything that I'm doing?
Or the project is just a hobby?
Or the project dies
because I can't figure out
a business model around it.
So with some networks, it's easier.
With YouTube, they have
built-in advertising,
so you can do that.
There's brand deals that are available.
You can sell your own merch
and different products.
There's a page around now that exists
that you can have your fans help find you.
A little bit harder with
the other platforms.
They haven't figured out the
monetization as much yet.
It could be for your business.
Toronto Dance Salsa has a business.
It's on social media.
We don't care about making
money from the videos
or from Twitter or brand deals.
It's about getting people
to sign up for salsa classes
and take lessons with us.
That's the main driver.
So whether you're
selling a product service
on the outside world,
whether you're trying to sell
to a specific demographic,
whether you're doing
advertising or brand deals,
understanding what your business model is
and then driving towards that
to try to make some money
so you can not just support
yourself, but build a team.
There's so many YouTubers.
I went to Clamour Con.
There's so many YouTubers with channels
that are bigger than mine,
that they're still doing
everything themselves
and they can't afford to
have anybody on their team.
They don't have a
business model around it.
They're just trying to drive
views and make content,
which is great and they love it.
But it's still just a hobby for them.
They need a business model around it,
and it was shocking that people
with millions of subscribers
still aren't making a
full-time income from it
and can't afford to hire
somebody underneath them.
Depends on the niche,
depends on a few factors,
but you got to be able to build
a business model around it
so you can support
yourself and set to build
a team to make your content more valuable.
(electronic music)
Which leads into number six,
which is to build a team!
You know, if you want to make
consistent, great
quality, awesome content,
you need to build a team.
You have to recognize
what you are fantastic at,
what are you best in
the world at, and then,
or potentially best in the
world if you're not there yet,
and then surround yourself with
people who can do the rest.
So for me, editing is
not what I'm great at.
For me, being a videographer
is not what I'm great at.
If you go back to my videos,
you'll see that they look worse
than what they do right now.
The camera's worse, the
editing is way worse.
I'm way worse on camera as well.
But I chose to spend my time
focusing on being a better speaker
and being better on the
research to pick the clips
that are going to make it into
the final versions for you guys,
and everything else gets assigned
to the people on my team.
So there's eight people
who work on my YouTube team
with different functions.
Some a full-time basis,
some in a part-time basis.
And that will allow us
to make more content.
How do you move from one video a week
to two a day to three a day?
How do you keep the consistency up
and the quality level up?
It's with a team.
And so that's where you
get more subscribers.
And it can start with
just one project, right?
The very first person that
I hired for my business,
we just made one
collaboration video together.
And that did well.
So, I went, okay, that did well
so we can work on something else.
As soon as I made money on my channel,
I poured it back into the business
to bring on my team so I can build it up,
build it up, build it up, build it up.
And so, you want to start eyeing,
what is the thing you hate
doing most in your business,
in your YouTube channel,
or in your social media?
If it's the graphic
design, it's the editing,
it's the filming, the research,
whatever it is that you hate the most.
Some people love being behind the camera.
They don't want to be in front.
Great, go partner up.
It doesn't even have to be paid, right?
There's some people, if you love editing,
there's people who love
being in front of the camera
and are looking for experience
in front of the camera.
Go work with them.
You don't have to pay them at the start.
Just build up your portfolio,
get your experience, get better.
Build up content, start
making a little bit of money,
and then you can afford
to have a budget to go and hire people.
(electronic music)
And tip number seven is model success.
And I love this tip.
It's always one of my go-to's.
If you're trying to figure out
what you should be doing in a new market,
one of the fastest ways of doing it
is look at what people are currently doing
and learn from them.
It doesn't mean you copy them.
You could learn a lot from my channel.
If you try to just copy me,
you're never going to
have massive success.
You'll just be an Evan Junior.
But you could learn from some
of the things that I'm doing
and apply it to your channel.
You could also learn from other industries
and bring them to your business.
So, you all, I learned
a lot for my channel
from guys like Darrel Eves,
from guys like Tim Schmoyer,
from guys like Casey Neistat,
from guys like Gary Vaynerchuk.
I learned from these people
who have done a lot more
and in a lot of cases,
my channel now has grown
to be bigger than their channels.
I've learned from them, and I
keep learning from more people
to make myself better.
I've learned from outside
industry, from the business world
that say hey, I think it's important
that everybody gets a
reply in their comments.
So I'm going to hire a team
of people to help me do that,
where most YouTube creators
can't keep up with the comments
so they just leave it.
They respond for 20 minutes after a video,
and then that's it.
They're gone.
I want everybody to get a response
so I build up a team.
And that just comes
from the business world.
If you look at Logan Paul
and the success that he's
had with his YouTube channel,
one of the fastest growing
YouTube channels of all time,
he came from the Vine world
and had success really quickly on YouTube,
implementing the strategies
that worked for him in Vine,
the six second videos,
applying them to YouTube.
And really capturing people
of short attention spans
and making high quality content
around him and on his vlogs.
So you can learn both from
people inside your industry
who you look up to, who
have had a lot of success
as well as people outside of the industry.
You can say huh, if I bring this,
this is something new that doesn't exist
that hasn't been done before.
I'm going to bring it and see if it works!
Try it, test it.
If it doesn't work, you can drop it.
But if it does, you run with it.
So that's my take on the
seven tips and tricks
to quickly get more subscribers.
I made this for you because
Luke Stinson asked me to.
So if there is a topic
you want me to cover
in a future seven ways,
check out the link in the subscription.
You can go and cast your vote.
Also, I'd love to know what
did you think of this video?
Did you like it?
Which tip was your favorite
from one of the seven?
Is there an eight, nine, 10 that I missed
that you want to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you guys have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Sahil Baisoya.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, taking a
picture, and sharing it.
I really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swoosh and crash)